there could be another round of hats and
t-shirts handed out on sunday night when
washington visits philadelphia the
washington football team hoping to win
and get in to the postseason as the nfc
east champions they will be doing so
without quarterback dwayne haskins not
just on the field but on the roster this
was a stunner yesterday i mean we kind
of knew after the strip club coveted 19
protocol breach last week that resulted
in a forty thousand dollar fine and a
removal of the c
from his jersey he had the pledge pin
taken off of his uniform by ron rivera
we knew that haskins was going to be
gone after 2020. we didn't expect it to
happen during the 2020 season but after
sunday and something happened sunday
night i don't know what i don't know and
i think it was precipitated by his
effort to skip out on the post-game
media obligation and their effort to
wrangle him to actually honor that
commitment right and where did he do
that caused him to say enough
did and did you notice that too in the
post game where was he like did he
finally end up doing it at home is that
where he ended up doing it from right he
probably was at home right right because
i know he is
he left yeah that's why i just and i
know i mean i watched it yesterday and
it was not a team facility background or
anything like that but i'm with you i'm
sorry to interrupt right there there
definitely must have something gone down
there you're right something happened
that caused them to say
screw it we could have held him into the
off season we could have tried to trade
him urban meyer may get back in the nfl
there was a sunday splash report that
urban meyer is is being courted by at
least two teams and he's gonna make a
decision this week as to whether or not
he's gonna come back if he would go to
the lions where chris spielman who has a
very high opinion of urban meyer is now
whispering into the ear of ownership if
he goes to the lions and they move on
from matthew stafford why not get dwayne
haskins right so washington could have
held him and you could argue should have
held him
with the opportunity to trade him and
avoid 4.2 million dollars in guaranteed
salary he's due to make in 2021 and 2022
whatever it was just
caused them to decide it's not worth it
the best interests of the team are to
get this guy out of here now we got to
write a check at some point for 4.2
million so be it although i think they
have a decent argument under his
contract that they could possibly avoid
that money given his behavior the
precipitated determination but but the
hell with it we we have to move on we're
better off moving on that tells you
whatever it was that occurred was going
to make it impossible for him to go back
into the locker room for the coaching
staff to accept him on that team yeah
that's right i mean they came to the
point where they just went this is not
going to work there's no chance of it
working here and
you know the young man's got to find a
new place and a new beginning all
together and kind of do some self
reflecting and figure out what direction
he wants to take his nfl career here you
know wait listen we saw some good things
this off season we saw a work ethic you
see he lost some weight he definitely
looks different on the you know on the
field in his uniform more trim met more
athletic running okay those are
positives but they're man there's just
too many other other things that are
negative you know whether it's the
actions then to me this is why they
probably released them i mean last week
it's it's playoff football we're it's do
or die for the washington football team
and
the main topic that the team had to talk
about for the first four days of last
week was their quarterback strip club
party whatever all that crap and listen
it's one thing to have somebody on the
team who did that it's a whole nother
thing when it's your freaking franchise
quarterback that takes the locker room
by storm everybody's gonna be talking
about that that's gonna become an issue
let alone we've seen a whole bunch of
other immature actions you know off the
field on the field all of it to where i
think they just realized hey let's cut
the cord it is a distraction we don't
believe in the player we're going to
move forward with our organization and
they'll reassess the qb situation as
they go
may 9
1997 is when he was born he's 23 years
old he's a combination of young
and and a little stupid a little
immature a little stupid and a little
entitled that 15th overall pick in the
draft it came with a 14 million fully
guaranteed contract it's not like it was
back in the days of ryan leaf where the
guy became untouchable
obviously he's not untouchable but that
was one of the problems with the
the old way they paid rookies you would
have guys top 10 top 15 they could do
whatever they wanted and there was
nothing the team could do because it was
going to wreak havoc on their salary cap
to let that much money walk out the door
with the player if they cut him well now
we see in this day and age you can rip
the band-aid off you can say get the
hell out of here even though they've
paid him 10 and they owe him another 4.2
if it comes to that and it quite
possibly will but it was better to just
get him out of there chris and uh you
know i i credit ron rivera for for being
decisive and for sending a message
because
if you do have the locker room turning
on the guy after what happened last week
and then he didn't play well on sunday
and if look if if you're going to get
redemption you earn redemption by by
showing up and playing well and then
there's this constant stream of
apologies from the guy he's he's
perfected the art of the apology yeah
but
but you have to keep apologizing maybe
that's why he's so good at apologies
he's so used to doing things that
require him to apologize
the apology seems sincere but then the
behavior doesn't change and and that's
going to be the warning sign for anyone
who who signs him in the offseason no
one's going to claim his contract on
waivers nobody's going to mess with him
as a free agent this year i'd be stunned
by that in the postseason if somebody
brings him in the question for next year
is
can you trust him and i think if urban
meyer gets back in how do you not how do
you not connect those two because he was
good at ohio state he was great at ohio
state sure he just came into the nfl
maybe a little too young maybe he should
have stayed at ohio state one more year
in hindsight i always say go get paid
while you can maybe this is an example
of somebody who should have maybe waited
one more year well yeah listen the the
the big thing is he's young like you're
saying i'm saying dwayne haskins you
still got a chance here it's not over
you still got a chance keep fighting the
good fight and you could still salvage
your career and and be something i mean
definitely you know yeah he's not going
to go somewhere and get you know
anointed or handed a job to be the
starter he's going to have to work to be
a backup quarterback right now in the
nfl but i wouldn't think there's some
teams that take a chance on him whether
it's urban meyer you know the guy is big
he does have a strong arm you do see
throws on film when you watch where you
go man that ball popped out of his hand
that looked pretty damn good you know
hey had pittsburgh steelers what would
it hurt to bring him in in the off
season you know maybe he can be
something down the road you know after
big ben who knows i don't know i think
there's going to be opportunities for at
least teams to look at him but i think
the last thing you said mike is the
point really it was a weird circumstance
for dwayne haskins he only played one
year of college football he was very
young he
is still very young
he was on a really good football team
that from quarterback the quarterback
aspect played the game very simple i
mean really simple and so not only is he
a young human being off the field he
really
young as well as far as football
knowledge experience things like that
you know ohio state was so sim so good
mike you know they they didn't and still
are but they don't they don't have to do
a lot on offense hey we're gonna keep
six or seven guys in the block we're
gonna send two or three receivers down
you don't really have to look at
protection we just want you to look at
that guy who's better than the guy
covering him or that guy who's better
than the guy covering him and when he's
open throw it to him okay easy enough
all right big guy throws makes the throw
oh here's a screen to paris campbell he
runs her 80 yard touchdown so it was all
of that the combination of all of it i
think really put him in a tough spot and
yeah obviously he was not ready for
prime time
you you you got my attention when you
mentioned the possibility of the
steelers for a couple of reasons first
of all one of the one of the points of
praise for mike tomlin with inside
football is he has that ability to get
through to guys whatever it takes to get
through to a guy and to get him to
perform tomlin knows how to handle those
personalities and knows how to manage
those personalities and second
i remember 2019 when we were looking at
film and talking about quarterbacks and
there was that narrative that was thrown
out there recklessly that dwayne haskins
isn't mobile which is the guy doesn't
run the ball down the field doesn't mean
he's not mobile and some of the stuff
that we saw him doing behind the line of
scrimmage
big banish kind of like big ben stuff
right yeah moving around buying time
moving laterally waiting for a guy to
get open getting rid of the football
having that that awareness that presence
that ability to extend plays without
taking off and and running the ball
uh
hey they've got to do
something and
there is no
magic easy answer as washington found
out by using the 15th overall pick on
dwayne haskins but if you can get this
guy for peanuts and you can get him into
your building and you can develop him to
be the successor to ben rothersberger
who they may need as soon as next year
based upon how roethlisberger's looked
this year and you may be onto something
there yeah i mean again
it's not going to be something where you
bring them in to go okay we need them as
a backup right now right no you bring
him in to be hey he's a third stringer
that we think maybe by the end of the 21
2021 season could be the backup and
maybe by 2022 or 2023 can be our
starting quarterback you know and you
know i would think there's a number of
teams that at least delve down the
wormhole of doing their research on
haskins
and
seeing if maybe there's a way he can fit
on their football team you know i would
think you know again i just throwing out
possibilities hey for him to go sit
behind a guy like deshawn watson in
houston and maybe this you know second
third string quarterback you know those
are the things he needs to be behind a
guy a pro and really learn from him see
what it takes take a backseat not have
the pressure of being the franchise guy
or being expected to play anytime soon
he just needs to grow in all areas of
life and i think you know i think he's
capable you you hear too many people
talk you know and say good things about
dwayne haskins you know as far as a
person this is not a bad guy it's not a
bad guy by any stretch of the
imagination you know that's one thing i
heard in the draft you hear urban meyer
he still talks very highly of him i just
think it's a young kid who's gotten
mixed up he's lost his way a little bit
and he's just got to get it back on the
straight and narrow and realize man when
you play quarterback in the nfl
it's it's it's you sacrifice everything
that's just the way it is you sacrifice
everything life is not normal you know
it's it's not yeah it's going to be a
little boring at times but you're
sacrificing that to have the most
amazing sunday afternoon 16 times a year
that are like you're the rock star
you're the man and sometimes you gotta
sacrifice not going to the strip club on
a sunday night or something like that
well and also you need a coach who's
invested in dwayne haskins and from the
moment ron rivera got the job and you
could tell he was ambivalent at best and
was it part of a jedi mind trick to coax
more out of dwayne haskins maybe it was
but
haskins wasn't rivera's guy that's a
real dynamic in football as well and
haskins was never a guy that rivera felt
the way that he should about and so you
need someone that's going to say we're
going to take the time we see where the
future is we're going to groom this guy
we're going to do everything we need to
do we're all in with him
and and he needs that kind of attention
and he needs that kind of guidance and
he needs that kind of leadership in
order to draw out of him what may be in
there but this is one of the products of
coming to the nfl at a very young age
after only one year of starting you need
to be groomed some guys can figure it
out on their own some guys need to be
shown what they need to do chris yeah
well think about it i mean we've seen
mahomes learn from alex smith we've seen
rogers learn from brett favre
you saw brady get behind bledsoe and he
was groomed as well a lot of great
quarterbacks terry bradshaw same thing
all of that and mike here's the other
thing too like because you're right you
got to get a support staff that believes
in you did anybody ever really believe
in him in washington really anybody from
day one other than the owner
and there's the problem there we go we
got the owner picking players again i
you know running businesses billionaire
gonna pick the damn quarterback no the
coaches the guys who know more than you
about the subject they don't love them
but you're gonna take them because why
he went to high school at the same high
school your son went to
like
i that's where
i feel bad for dwayne haskins and i
don't feel bad for dan cider in the
washington organization because it's
always crap like that and it's just it's
it's hard to get behind it and then now
they're in a tough spot but damn they
made their bed and now you gotta lay in
it and i feel bad for ron navera because
now he's got to deal with it
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports